We were talking about relativity and uh,
where we ended up last time,
we're talking about special relativity and all the weird things that happened to
space and time.
And the question arose,
you know,
what prompted Einstein to think these thoughts?
And we talked a little bit about,
uh,
the fact that the speed of light is always the same no matter what the velocity
of the person observing it.
And how,
uh,
that,
then if you take that literally it tells you that space and time are weird and
a,
and are not constant and absolute the way you might think.
They are a in a Newtonian sense,
but,
uh,
but very according to the velocity of the observer and uh,
in,
in these various ways having to do with that parameter gamma.
And so Einstein's great stroke of genius was not to try and fix up these little
problems with the experiment in some sort of patchwork kind of way or to try and
evoke a minor change in,
in the laws of nature,
but to recognize that this was a very big deal.
And that would involve changing fundamentally how we think space.
And time work.
So this is a very famous fable of science.
You know,
this is the thing where Einstein is a young man and he's sort of,
uh,
he sort of a rebel and he refuses to take his exam and he pisses off his
professors,
uh,
and the consequences.
He doesn't get a good job.
And,
uh,
he gets this job at the patent office right in a,
in Bern,
Switzerland where he labors away in obscurity and then suddenly in a blaze of
glory glory in 1905,
he publishes three papers,
one of which is about relativity,
one of which is the start of quantum mechanics.
And the other one of which proves that Adam's exist.
Uh,
and so these are three of the greatest papers of all time published in a single
year by some clown who was a clerk in a patent office.
All right?
Very big deal.
This happened in 1905,
two years ago.
It was the hundredth anniversary of this.
This was declared Einstein year,
and all sorts of fuss was made about it.
So there are various morals that can be drawn from this.
Uh,
and I'm going to draw several of them in what you might call increasing order of
sophistication.
So the,
uh,
the low sophistication,
moral moral number one here is,
you know,
about the genius in obscurity.
No Genius in obscurity,
uh,
can revolutionize science.
Uh,
this is a very dangerous way to approach the Einstein story because it,
you know,
it's really easy to convince yourself that you are a genius in obscurity.
Uh,
many people have convinced themselves that they are genius is it?
It's your obscurity.
I know about this cause they send me email,
uh,
and they explained to me in their email that they send me,
and this happens to,
you know,
any,
any scientists,
particularly someone working in astrophysics or fundamental physics of some
kind.
They explained to me why Einstein was wrong.
Uh,
anti deed,
why all science known to date is wrong and they are bright.
And then they said,
you know,
nobody believed Einstein either.
Uh,
and uh,
as if that was somehow meant to make you believe them.
They tend to write these things all in capital letters.
You know,
uh,
there's a,
there's a kind of pathology when they used to write,
when they used to do it on,
on Pencil and paper,
they would write in such a way that they covered every inch of the paper and you
know,
they'd write something,
then they'd ride around the margins back to the top.
Uh,
there's some psychological thing.
I don't know what it is.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but the legend of Einstein prompts a whole bunch of people to think that,
that they too might be a patent.
Clark's yes.
Huh.
Oh,
well look,
uh,
you can look up the astronomy department website of Harvard,
Yale,
and Princeton and you'll find a whole bunch of people,
I suppose.
Uh,
I also have have published papers on black holes and things that made their way
into the media.
I've actually had a fall off on this because I haven't been,
you know,
quoted opining about black holes in the New York Times recently,
but,
but 10 years ago,
uh,
that,
well,
I'll explain that in a couple of weeks there,
there was an interesting,
an interesting thing that happened.
Uh,
in any case,
uh,
you know,
if,
if you want to publicize your theory,
what you do is you find a bunch of fairly prominent people in the field and you
send them a big screen saying,
you know,
uh,
you will regret it if you do not appreciate my genius.
Uh,
uh,
sometimes I do.
We have a little file in the library called the crank file in the astronomy
department library.
And from time to time,
uh,
you know,
we assigned graduate students to figure out why they're wrong.
Uh,
uh,
we haven't done,
we haven't done that lately.
Sometimes,
sometimes people,
uh,
people amusing themselves by answering them.
Uh,
this can get you into various kinds of trouble.
there was the gentleman with the theory of the universe who,
which he illustrated in colored pencils a and while he was serving his time at a
medium security institution in Wa in Washington State.
And we thought,
you know,
what a great way to,
much better way to be spending your time in prison than some other things you
could think of.
So we sent him a bunch of textbooks and stuff.
Then we started getting letters back saying,
after I finished my sentence,
my sentence,
I'm coming to study with you and explaining why he was innocent of the crime of
which he had been committed.
And,
uh,
so at a certain point we started returning things,
you know,
no terribly sorry.
This individual has left Yale.
We gone to where he is,
whoever this is,
carry a rose who carried on this conversation for a while.
Uh,
and so you have to be a little bit careful.
And there though,
there was the guy,
this was amazing.
Uh,
there was a guy who showed up at the start of the semester.
He's dressed a suit and tie,
carrying a briefcase,
walks into the department office.
It says,
where's my classroom?
I'm supposed to teach cosmology.
And uh,
you know,
look very respectable.
The secretary thoughts not with us.
You're not.
So send them over to the physics department.
He asked the same question in the physics department.
It just walked in off the street with a,
uh,
with a briefcase full of his textbook.
Uh,
and he was very annoyed that we hadn't assigned him a classroom and assigned
students to come and learn,
you know,
his particularly theory of cosmology.
Uh,
and in the anti you had to be escorted off the premises and asked never to
return.
So yeah,
all kinds of patent clerks in the world,
but most of them aren't.
Einstein.
That's kind of the moral and the reason you can tell you,
you asked whether I read these things,
it's very easy to tell whether there's anything,
uh,
that you might immunize the Mike be useful to read.
Uh,
because what these people tend to say when they are not worth reading is they
sent,
tend to say that all previous science is wrong.
I am revolutionizing things.
Einstein is wrong,
they say,
but Einstein didn't say that Newton was wrong.
That wasn't what happened.
That wasn't how revolution works.
Uh,
you revolutionize science only if the new theory
encompasses what was previously no.
Okay.
The previous theories,
and this is this business of the parameter gamma where,
uh,
under appropriate circumstances,
a gamma is one.
And under those circumstances,
you reproduce the theory that was already in existence.
It's,
and so,
you know,
there's been hundreds and hundreds of years of Newtonian physics,
all of which is basically right,
one way or another.
So whatever your new idea is,
has to encompass all the things that we're right about the old idea.
And so you don't overturn Newton.
What you do is you demonstrate that Newton's theory is only a part of a bigger
theory.
And then the bigger theory is the new theory.
And it encompasses new kinds of data and explain to new kinds of things while
simultaneously not overturning all the things that you know are right about the
old theory.
And this is the thing that the people who wish they were Einstein but aren't,
uh,
don't understand.
Uh,
and so anytime you see something where you're,
where they're going to revolutionize all of science,
it's certainly wrong because there's a large fraction of science in current
existence that is correct.
And you have to understand that and you have to encompass it and go beyond that.
Uh,
but it's not going to get overturned.
The planets aren't going to stop going and capillary in orbit because somebody
has a new idea.
And so it has to encompass the old idea.
Recently in conjunction in part with Einstein year or two years ago,
the historians of science have been,
have been rethinking what's going on with Einstein,
uh,
and what happened in that patent office.
And there's a new,
uh,
kind of idea that actually it was,
it wasn't that he was working in obscurity and some in,
in,
you know,
flipping burgers or something that his work in the patent office was very
important to the way he developed his theory.
And that,
one of the reasons Einstein,
uh,
did what he did was he was working in a patent office and not in a university
because what was he doing in the patent office?
Well,
it turns out that in the early part of the 20th century,
one of the big set of inventions that was coming through were ways of
synchronizing clocks.
Uh,
it turns because railroads had just been invented.
And until then you had had a situation where every city had its own time.
Every city,
every city had a little observatory.
They would figure out when the sun was directly overhead,
they would proclaim that to be noon.
They'd fire off a whistle.
Everyone would set all their clocks.
But that meant that they didn't have time zones.
And that meant that every little town had a different time system.
There was Boston time was different from Hartford time with different buy new
from New York time by,
you know,
22 and a half minutes or whatever the appropriate amount would be.
And that's all fine if you move between these cities slowly,
if you start running trains,
you've got to have,
the train system has to have a unified system of,
of time.
Otherwise they run into each other,
uh,
and there were crashes and terrible things.
And so then you have to have,
okay,
then you have to have Boston and New York having the same time.
So how do you synchronize those clocks?
Well,
you've just invented the Telegraph.
So you send an,
you send an electromagnetic signal at the speed of light from Boston to New York
and then back again in order to synchronize your clocks.
And there were various inventions that,
that Einstein was reviewing in the patent office to accomplish this.
And so he,
in his job,
in his day job,
he spent all his time thinking about clocks and time and signals moving at the
speed of light.
So perhaps it isn't surprising that he had deep insights into these kinds of
things.
So,
uh,
the,
the current feeling among at least some historians of science is that the patent
office,
uh,
was in fact key to Einstein's thinking.
So he didn't come out of obscurity at all.
He came out of the only place where the surroundings were,
such that you would have thought these thoughts.
Uh,
this is associated with a,
uh,
a historian of science named Peter Galison,
among others who wrote a book called Einstein's clocks and Poincare's maps to
try and demonstrate how the practical work these people were doing influenced
their theoreticals work.
Yes.
Well,
no,
he was,
he triggered by one particular event.
What prompted him to think about this was a whole series of experiments that had
been carried out,
all of which,
as I mentioned last time,
one way or another,
uh,
demonstrated,
that this business at the speed of light was constant in all reference frames.
Uh,
and,
and that there was no ether through,
which was the medium that was imagined to exist through which electromagnetic
waves were supposed to pass.
And there had been a series of experiments to try and detect slight changes in
the speed of light when you put it on a railroad,
when you put it on after train,
right.
It's all about trains and elevators,
which had just been invented.
Uh,
and,
uh,
but it wasn't one particular triggering event.
There was this whole range of things.
And Einstein,
it should be said,
was by far not the only person thinking about this.
We call the transformation Lorentz transformations.
Cause there was a guy named Lorenz who thought them up,
uh,
mathematicians like punk Carre,
physicists like Minkowski.
There were a whole bunch of people thinking about this and it was an urgent
problem in physics.
Uh,
and uh,
so that had to be dealt with.
And if Einstein hadn't existed,
it might've taken a little longer,
but we would've,
we would've gotten special relativity,
uh,
in the end.
That's not necessarily true of general relativity.
He has,
I'll explain in a second,
general relativity,
if Einstein hadn't existed,
general relativity might not have happened until the 1960s because it was not
prompted by a range of experimental results.
The other bunch of experimental results,
uh,
that were prominent at the time where the,
where the atomic physics experiments that led to quantum mechanics,
which Einstein had a hand in as well.
Okay.
Uh,
so now let me move on to two general relativity.
That's a,
that's a good moment to make this transition.
Uh,
so general relativity known as Gr for short,
uh,
is now a theory of gravity.
So the part of Newtonian physics that is overthrown or,
uh,
encompassed as I was saying,
by special relativity are the laws of motion.
Uh,
now general relativity has the law,
those same laws of motion but also has embedded in it a theory of gravity,
which is fundamentally different from the way Newton thought about gravity.
So Newtonian gravity,
uh,
yes,
thought of as a force to particular force.
It's the force of gravity.
There's a little equation.
Uh,
the force of gravity is equal to the gravitational constant g times the mass of
one object times the mass of the other object divided by the distance between
them square.
Uh,
and the odd thing,
and this was sort of the starting point of Einstein's thought,
the odd thing is these masses.
And because remember somebody asked me last time what is mass?
And I gave you a whole thing about the inertial mass,
how much it resists being pushed.
And that comes about from,
you know,
f equals m a.
And so the kind of mass that I defined last time is the inertial mass,
how much it resists being pushed.
Uh,
and so conceptually the mass that's in the,
in,
in Newton's equations of gravity,
conceptually that's a different kind of mass.
It doesn't have to be the same number.
This is gravitational mass because it's defined differently.
It's defined not by how much an object resists being pushed by a force,
any force,
but by how much the object create a particular kind of force.
So in this,
it's how much it resists forces in this.
It's how much the force is created.
And these are conceptually different things.
It turns out that to the best experimental evidence that you,
uh,
that you can muster,
which by now is many,
many decimal places.
These two kinds of mass are exactly the same.
This has,
uh,
an experimental consequence that was known already to Galileo in the 17th
century.
Look,
what happens.
Supposing [inaudible] is the earth and m two is some object that is that you're
dropping from a high tower.
So,
uh,
the stories Galileo goes to the top of,
that's how our piece that he drops a cannon ball or something and watches it,
watches it fall.
Then what happens?
Uh,
you,
you substitute a f gravity into the equation of motion
and what do you get?
So you're using a particular kind of force.
So you get g m of the object am of the earth,
uh,
divided by distance squared where the distance is the distance between the
centers of the object.
So this is basically the distance to the center of the earth is equal to the
mass of the object times its acceleration.
And look,
if this mass is the same as that mass they canceled.
What does that mean?
So when you can do this,
it means it means the motion,
the acceleration of the object doesn't depend on its mass.
The acceleration of the object will be the same for any object because if it has
greater inertia,
it also generates by exactly a proportional amount,
a greater force.
And so everything falls from the tower at the same rate.
And that's what,
that's what Galileo did.
He brought up a cannon ball and a wooden ball and a whole bunch of other objects
dropped them and discovered that,
uh,
that the Greeks had been wrong.
The Greeks and match and the heavier the thing is,
the faster it falls.
But the only reason you think that is because of dropping things like feathers,
which do fall kind of slowly and erotically.
That has nothing to do with gravity.
That's air pressure,
right?
And so if you drop things that are heavy enough so that air pressure isn't
important,
they fall at the same rate.
So that is the experiment that proves that gravitational mass is the same as
inertial mass.
All other forces don't have this consequence.
There is,
for example,
I'll,
let me not draw on the corner here.
How be just like the,
the cranks,
you know,
I'll start drawing all the way around the edge of the,
the thing here.
Uh,
so let us go on.
let's see.
Uh,
there is,
for example,
uh,
electrical force,
which has,
uh,
a very similar kind of equation.
That's a constant,
the times the charge of one object times the charge of another object divided by
the distance between them squared,
that looks almost identical to what the gravitational force looks like.
But because the charge of an object isn't equal to its mass,
different objects respond differently to,
uh,
put in,
when,
when an electric force is exerted on them.
If you compare a proton,
which is a bass of sub Tomic particle of charge one with a positron,
which is a low mass particle of charge one,
and you put the same amount of force on them,
the positron will move much more because it has so much less mass.
And so different objects respond in different ways to all forces except it.
So the unusual thing about gravity,
so gravity is weird,
okay?
Because
yeah,
the gravitational mass turns out to be
exactly equal,
at least to the best possible measurement to the inertial mass.
Okay?
And there's no excuse within Newtonian theory to explain why that might be and
why all objects move,
therefore,
move the same subject when,
when,
uh,
when put in a gravitational field.
Okay.
So this bugged Einstein.
This is the kind of thing that,
that,
that bothered him.
And so,
uh,
to explain this and other,
related sort of conceptual issues,
uh,
he promulgated a completely different theory.
Uh,
namely.
so Einstein says,
okay,
so gravity Einstein says is not a force.
That's not the right way to think about it.
Yeah.
Uh,
and so what,
how does this work then?
All right.
So 0.1 objects move in a straight line when they are not in a straight line.
In the absence
of a force.
Yeah.
This is,
you know,
Newton's first law or something.
You know,
if you're,
uh,
if you're moving at a constant velocity will continue moving in the same
direction at the same speed unless something happens,
like a force is applied to you.
If gravity isn't a force that should still be true,
objects are moving in straight lines,
uh,
all the time.
Whether there's a gravitate,
whether there's gravity around or not.
Uh,
that seems very odd because we know perfectly well the things that when you have
a gravitational force and you're in an orbit,
you go around in a circle,
not in a straight line at all.
So how does a,
an Einstein reconcile this with reality?
Uh,
and that's part two of the theory.
Part two of the theory is that the presence of mass
inertial mass now,
uh,
create
curvature
in space,
time,
space and time.
Okay.
Now how does that help?
That helps because,
uh,
because you have to then go back and think,
what do you mean by going in a straight line?
If you're in a curved space?
And I'll give you some examples of this,
uh,
that you can see in a minute.
Uh,
what you mean by a straight line is the shortest distance between two points.
Now,
okay,
we know from experience or many of us know from experience that on a curved
space,
uh,
the,
shortest difference between two points is not exactly what you expect it to be.
Uh,
has anyone flown on an airplane from here to Asia,
for example,
fly from New York to Beijing?
Uh,
so let's make a map a flat map.
So here's a flat space,
uh,
north,
east,
west,
south.
Here's New York,
here's Beijing.
And you might imagine if things were flat,
that the way you would get in,
the quickest way that the airlines would save money,
you know,
because they don't,
that is that they would fly directly east because it's more or less at the same
latitude in New York and Beijing.
But that isn't what happens.
That isn't what happens at all.
What you do,
if you,
if you fly that route or if you go the other way to,
to,
to Europe,
wherever it is that you're going,
um,
is you fly this way,
you go way up north,
you've looked down halfway through,
there's the Arctic.
Why do you do that?
It's because the earth isn't flat.
The earth is a sphere.
And so what it really looks like is this.
Here's,
here's,
here's the earth.
Uh,
here's New York,
here's Beijing.
And you fly this way because that's the shortest distance across a,
the surface of a sphere between two points.
Uh,
I have a severe somewhere.
Um,
let's see.
Here's a sphere,
uh,
and uh,
this line here,
uh,
think of this as the equator.
And if you go from here to here,
it would be the shortest distance between the two points would be to go right
across the equator.
But we're not going on the equator.
We're in the northern hemisphere.
So now I'm going to tip this upward so that these two things are both in the
northern hemisphere and now this line goes up and across.
And if I tip it all the way up so that he,
you know,
so that you would be dealing with two cities on the opposite side of the world
as,
as New York and Beijing,
and close enough it goes,
the closest line between them doesn't go around this way.
It goes straight up over the top.
So if you project that onto a flat map,
it looks like this,
but in fact,
a on a sphere on the surface of this sphere,
that is the shortest distance between those two points.
It's the exact same distance as it would be,
uh,
in,
in the equator.
You just tip the thing up and it's clear that this is the long way round.
So if you have a curved space and uh,
uh,
and you're trying to get in the shortest way from one point to another and you
don't know you're on a curved space,
you would interpret it as a flat space,
then you will interpret the path that you take as curved.
And so Einstein's statement is that the presence of mass doesn't exert a
gravitational force.
That's the wrong way to think about it.
What it does is he creates a curvature in the space time.
And so then objects traveling from one place to another.
Uh,
move in,
move in straight lines to define just the shortest distance between those two
points.
But if we're not taking the curvature into account,
it looks like it's going around in circles.
All right.
Tough concept.
The sheet is supposed to represent spacetime.
Uh,
spacetime is,
and now,
uh,
now I got to explain that,
right?
Uh,
so,
uh,
what is space time?
Uh,
because it's space time that's doing the curving.
it's,
you can think of it as a four dimensional,
as a four dimensional,
a coordinate system,
uh,
where the four dimensions are,
the three familiar spatial dimensions,
x,
Y,
Z and t for time.
And you could understand where any given event,
where an event is something that happens can be identified with four numbers.
It's spacial position.
That's three numbers and the time at which it occurs.
Now in order to get these things into the same units,
you have to actually represent it to this as the speed of light times time
because that track multiplying by the speed of light turns time,
units into space units cause this is a miles per hour space per time.
So one year of time is the equivalent of one light year of distance.
That's how it converts.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
one interesting thing and of course this sheet there was a two dimensional space
and only had x and y that could identify any point on the sheet.
So the metaphor is to use to spacial dimensions to represent what is actually a
for uh,
conceptually afforded mentioned space.
That's why it's a metaphor and not something real.
Yes.
Uh,
yes,
absolutely correct.
Does gravity bend time too?
It has an effect on time.
Similar to time dilation.
When you're going really fast,
if you get really close to a back black hole,
your clocks will slow down.
Yeah.
Yes.
Why is that?
Uh,
let me,
uh,
next time I'll write down the Schwab trialed metric and I'll try and answer that
question.
Um,
let me,
let me go on here for a minute and,
and point out an important thing about this,
uh,
this,
agreement here,
which is,
uh,
that means the earth in its motion.
For example,
in one year,
the time coordinate moves one light year,
which is 10 to the 16 meters.
The space coordinate moves two Pi Times.
The Sami major axis,
which is one astronomical unit,
uh,
that two Pi Times 1.5 times 10 to the 11 meters,
that's something like 10 to the 12 meters.
So the Earth moves 10,000 times further in time.
Then it moves in space in a year.
And that means that the earth's or the earth's motion in spacetime is almost
precisely a straight line going straight forward in time.
So here's time.
Here's,
I don't know if the x axis,
and you could imagine that as time goes on,
the earth moves around the sun.
So it's x axis.
So it's x coordinate,
goes back and back and back and forth.
Here's The sun,
which,
uh,
you know,
wiggles a little bit,
much less than the earth as we discussed.
Uh,
but this,
uh,
this picture here is inaccurate because in fact,
this,
uh,
this distant here,
which is half a year,
is 10,000 times longer than this distance here,
which is half an orbit.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
and so in fact,
the earth's motion is represented by something that's almost exactly a straight
line,
so much so that I couldn't possibly draw the wiggle in a way that you could see
it.
So here's the earth,
uh,
going forward in time and the wiggle is really small.
That's not surprising because the gravitational force of,
uh,
of the sun is small enough so that the Earth's orbit is correctly described by
Newtonian physics.
And so this is one of those situations where you have a Newtonian,
uh,
a Newtonian physics,
in relatively low gravitational fields and ask the gravitational field to get
stronger,
uh,
weird relativistic effects kick in,
but that doesn't happen for the earth.
So there's,
uh,
the number is this Schwartzwald radius divided by distance is the measure of how
relativistic,
uh,
and orbit is.
And if this number is small,
then you get correct answers from the new Tony in theory,
and we can work it out.
Dishwasher radius of the sun,
three times 10 to the three meters,
the distance from the earth to the sun,
1.5 times 10 to the 11 meters,
that's two times 10 to the minus eight.
Uh,
and that's a small number.
So earth works fine in a Newtonian sense.
Yes.
Are the reason orbital radius,
that is the distance of the moving object from the center of the gravitating
thing that's making the,
the curvature happened.
Yeah.
So yes is the answer.
It's the radius of the orbit.
Yes.
Is the theory of general relativity
theory that would probably get it.
Third visit actually have equation.
Oh yes.
Uh,
does it have a questions associated with it?
You Bet.
Uh,
you don't want to see them.
there's a branch of mathematics called differential geometry,
uh,
because the,
what happens is,
you know,
this curvature stuff is all geometry and the problem is that the further away
you get from an object,
the less the space is curved.
So the amount of on the sphere,
on the surface of the sphere,
it's curved the same way everywhere.
So the equations that describe the curvature or the same at any point on a
sphere,
but you can imagine something that starts out with strong curvature and tails
off.
And then the amount of curvature at any given point is different from any other
point.
So you have to describe it with a differential amount of curvature and then you
integrate over the path that thinks,
take this,
get heinous.
Uh,
and we're not going to go there,
but I will show you next time some specific examples of some of these equations
because it'll help explain things like why space and time are reversed inside an
event horizon and stuff.
But yeah,
you bet.
There's a whole mathematical theory.
In fact,
Einstein was not the world's greatest mathematician and it took him until 1917
to get all this worked out.
He had to go and get himself some math tutoring at the University of Gooding and
so that he could understand the,
uh,
the geometric properties.
Uh,
so yeah,
there's a big mathematical theory behind it.
Yes.
So if,
um,
if gravity is not a force,
how can you use that equals
Oh,
f equals m a is a,
uh,
is a general equation of motion.
Okay.
It doesn't have to be the force of gravity.
There are many other forces in the world,
but when you're setting f equals m a to GM,
right?
So that's the Newtonian idea that you set.
F equals m a equal to GMM m over d squared.
Uh,
and the thing that prompted Einstein's thought was the fact that the two
different kinds of masses on each side of the equation turned out to be equal.
And you can see why this explains that.
Because if what's happening is that you curve space and then things follow a
trajectory dictated by the curvature of that space,
then it makes perfect sense that all objects follow the same trajectory
regardless of their mass,
cause they're not actually being forced to move anywhere.
They're just going in straight lines.
And straight lines are the same no matter what your mass is.
And so that's why this kind of curvature,
uh,
provide an explanation for what in the Newtonian approximation is the equality
of the inertial and the gravitational mass.
How are we doing?
Oh,
we got some more time.
Good.
Go ahead.
Literally slow down as you move towards the
perception of,
well,
of course you are a clock,
right?
Uh,
you're,
you,
no,
you wouldn't notice.
But what would happen is this,
supposing you're falling into a,
to a black hole or something,
uh,
you look at your clock,
you,
you feel your pulse.
You know,
your pulse metric by your clock is,
it has not changed.
Uh,
but you look back out into the world that is distant from the black hole and
things are moving really fast out there.
And so if you had two synchronized,
identical clocks at the start of your voyage,
and you keep an eye on what's happening out here,
uh,
you will discover that all of a sudden it looks like your clock is moving slow
and all of a sudden,
you know,
people are aging and dying back on earth.
A while,
you know,
it's only been a week in your,
uh,
in your perception.
And so you turn it around,
you're sitting on earth watching your friend fall through,
fall into a black hole,
and it looks like he's slowing down and slowing down and slowing down in and
maybe never really quite get to the event horizon even in an infinite amount of
time.
But the perception of the person falling through is that they just fall through.
It's just the whole universe has evolved in the time that they've done it.
Uh,
so it's one of these weird things where time turns out how fast time passes
turns out to be a property of who's doing the measuring.
Very strange concept and very counterintuitive to the way we live our life
because we all think because we live in low gravitational fields at low speeds,
uh,
we think time is an absolute thing that ticks on word for everybody in the same
way.
But it turns out it isn't true.
Yes.
Oh,
and uh,
again,
I'll show you an equation that actually this is much easier to deal with in
equations than it is conceptually a,
and I'll show you an equation next time,
uh,
which,
may help.
Can you explain what the names behind the two theories of relativity?
I mean,
it doesn't seem like the general theory is a generalization,
but,
uh,
it,
it actually is because it incorporates aspects of the special theory and,
and it's a generalization in terms of what's called the metric.
The metric is the mathematical formula that describes the curvature and the
special theory of relativity is the special case where the metric is flat and
then the jet jet.
The reason general relativity as a generalization is because it allows,
uh,
other,
in many other kinds of metrics.
Okay.
Well,
at least that's one,
that's one way of thinking about it.
Yes,
sir.
Second one.
Yeah.
Well,
I too small for me to draw the wiggles from the motion of the earth around the
sun and it's caused by the mass of the sun.
Warps the space.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's just all,
all,
all I meant in the second one.
Sorry,
I didn't explain this clearly.
All I meant in the second one was,
uh,
that this one is inaccurate in terms of scale
and that the scale,
the true scale is such that,
that,
that this length thought it'd be 10,000 times longer than that,
and under those circumstances,
you'd never be able to see it.
That's all I meant by that.
Yeah.
What happens to time when you're traveling?
You mentioned this,
but what happens at times when you're traveling close to the speed of life slows
down.
Yeah.
Yes.
I'm not sure.
I'm getting a little confused because you said now that gravity is,
and of course anymore,
but like all our lives who've been exploited,
like that's why we see on earth.
How does that,
ah,
so how does,
how does this work?
Um,
right.
Uh,
we are,
you know,
you can explain the motion of the earth in terms of uh,
these so called space time diagrams where one,
you,
you take the four dimensional thing,
you projected onto two dimensions.
You can write a spacetime diagram for yourself and you can explain all of the
motion and all of the things that happen,
uh,
by,
such a curves thing.
So what happens if your jump,
for example,
in the Newtonian theory,
uh,
you jump,
you ought to keep going straight up.
Uh,
except that there's a force which pulls you back down so that we understand what
happens.
How is that explained in general relativity?
You jump and,
uh,
you go in a straight line,
but the straight line is through a curved space curve because of the presence of
the earth.
And so it turns out that the straight line looks like this.
It goes up and comes back down again,
uh,
in just the same way that the straight line between New York and Beijing goes
over the North Pole.
It goes up and comes back down again because space is space.
Time is curved due to the gravity of the earth.
So something that we perceive to be a curve trajectory,
jumping up,
falling back down if you projected into space time,
is actually the closest distance between two events.
So there's two alternative explanations of these things in the situation where
you're nowhere near a black hole.
It turns out that mathematically there exactly equivalent.
If they are exactly equivalent,
it's much easier to calculate the Newtonian way and much easier to think about
it.
So until you get into a situation where,
uh,
the swatch showed radius is comparable to the distances involved a,
you're way better off thinking Newtonian,
like,
because you know,
we're just better at it.
Yes,
I understand that in order to get units that you can line up in any way
meaningfully,
you need to multiply time of philosophy.
I'm a little confused about it.
End of the sea important.
But if the only reason why,
um,
the,
you know,
the wiggles and that graph of are really tiny is because c is so enormous.
I mean,
couldn't you pick another velocity?
Right?
What makes that inaccurate?
Okay,
so the reason that's an accurate scaling is one of the things that comes out of
the theory of relativity is that there is a natural unit.
There's a natural set of units and the natural set of units or the units in
which these crucial constants of which C is one and g is another and h the
Planck constant,
which governs,
uh,
quantum mechanics are all equal to one.
And that turns there that those are called Planck units.
And they have,
uh,
and,
and the conversion between different kinds of energy,
mass to energy,
things like that.
Uh,
all workout as equalities in the particular set of units where all those
constants come out to be one.
So,
uh,
there is a reason why that particular Po,
why that particular velocity is chosen.
And it's not surprising if you had to pick a velocity that you would end up with
the speed of light,
which has this sort of profound importance.
Okay,
we'll continue next time.